welcome to episode 35 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this podcast i spoke with dr ali
saviarvi
one of the world's top biohackers he's a
pioneer of holistic and preventative
medicine in finland
and the author of biohacker's handbook a
textbook of a guide
to everything biohacking he was a hoot
honestly the episode made me want to
laugh more than a few times i'm not sure
if i actually laughed out loud
but i was suppressing it a lot it was
fantastic
we discussed sleep nutrition stress
management
and optimal recovery among other things
he explained in more practical terms
what can easily be adopted by anyone to
start improving their habits and
trying to take control of their personal
health which is
very difficult to control for some
people
the episode was super interesting and
way more entertaining than you would
assume
i hope you enjoy it if you do please
rate the podcast and subscribe
leave a comment etc stay tuned for the
episode
sunday with wim hof and my dad
if you're trying to find an easy way to
eat healthy my go-to meat is from true
local that's tru local they connect you
with local butchers and get flash frozen
sustainably raised meat to your door
and you should also support them because
they support me and my little
podcast i get a box every two weeks and
i have been for
three years i believe and my favorite
food from them is the
grain-fed beef that's grass-fed grain
finished
although they also sell pure grass-fed
they're wild salmon but
mainly their lamb is to die for also
it's nice that they're supporting local
farmers and ethically raised meat
sustainably raised meat they're just
good guys over at true local
with good meat good hearts supporting me
making the world a better place one lab
at a time
you guys get it with code mp you get
free steaks
try them out let me know what you think
also before i start my newsletter is
linked below in the show notes and at
michaelapedersen.com
and you should sign up if you want to
stay updated for me in case i ever get
kicked off of socials for
complaining about doctors or viruses or
pandemics or sugar or politics who knows
i don't complain about all doctors i am
interviewing a doctor here
just most of them okay enjoy this
episode with dr
ali savi-yarvey
[Music]
dr ali saviarvi i hope i didn't destroy
that name too much
welcome to my show hey thanks this is a
pleasure
and finally we are here i know we've
been rebooking this for
a very long time since serbia i have
your book here
put it up here um which i have yep
so i've been very excited to talk to you
because i have
just a number of questions that i want
to throw at you for the audience
and mainly for selfish reasons
um so i think we should get started well
can you give
the people watching a brief background
about who you are and what it is that
you do
yeah sure my background is in like
western medicine
so i'm a medical doctor graduated 2006
from
helsinki university and i've been doing
a lot of different kinds of
jobs in the medical field one of the
hardest part was like this five year
period
of going around the country and being on
call
almost like five years straight so in
one week i
might have been in seven different
places around the country so
i was basically everywhere so this is
also why the stress
as a topic is so important for me and
especially the stress management because
i was
almost that five years in constant
like alarm state so at any point of time
uh any anybody from the medical company
call me okay you have to go there
okay there's a lot of patient traffic in
the er you have to go there
and you know so on after that uh it was
probably 2010
11 i began studying more of
like psychology and philosophy in the
journal of kennedy university
so this was basically the integral
theory studies
i did there and from there on i went on
developing my own career as like a
private practitioner
and also like gravitating more towards
the holistic medicine
and eventually by hacking back in 2013
and here we are with the bikers handbook
we have a
biker center company since 2015
and we produce a lot of material
and at the moment i'm not taking
patients anymore i quit that
2018 and we are solely concentrating on
preventive health so creating the
preventive health care system is
is the ultimate plan here
yeah well that's that's ideal um for
people who don't know what
is biohacking everybody is a biker
at least any person who's interested
in his own health and likes to do
experiment with him or herself so
uh biohacker uses natural biological
nutritional and technical technological
means
to improve one's health energy levels
mood and overall balance in life
and especially in finland the biohacking
is very
nature oriented of course we like thick
but we also like to combine the
technology with nature
so that is ultimately the biohacking you
don't
need to measure anything if you don't
want but
of course quantifying yourself is the
part of it
so becoming aware of what you want to
change
to actually change is really functioning
a lot better
okay um what are the like if someone has
no idea where to start what are the
most important elements behind
biohacking
definitely as it was for me was fixing
your sleep
and what i mean by that i was
chronically
sleep deprived let's say from
even since the beginning of medical
school or actually it began
when i was in the army for one year and
that's
you know it's mandatory in finland so uh
we didn't sleep that much
and i'm pretty like sensitive of a
sensitive nervous system
and i react to like different kind of
stimuli so i was
basically from there on chronically
sleep deprived
so after quitting this five-year period
of
being on call all the time the first
thing
i fixed was the sleep so i realized
after using
i think it was the sleep cycle app back
in 2009 or 10
i realized i slept only like five and a
half hours per night
and it wasn't really good quality sleep
of course i took naps but
definitely that wasn't enough so
beginning
to optimize or even even pay attention
to your sleep qualities that's the
number one point
and usually after that people are going
to be
very interested in nutrition i think
especially your followers and your lion
diet and you know the approach
you do which is pretty wonderful what
you have been
able to do for a certain group of people
that actually works so the nutrition
part is critical
so finding what's actually working for
you
at this specific time it might be
different
like after two years or it might it
might look very different
from like let's say five years ago so
being adaptable to your personal needs
in nutrition and after that comes like
stress management
optimal recovery the balance of the mind
different kind of meditation techniques
breeding practices
and so on so everyone has a different
kind of path
in biohacking and that's that's the idea
of it its n equals one experiment
so you are your own kind of like a
subject or object of research
yeah that's great that's the best way to
figure things out right
uh okay so let's start with uh and i do
really want to get into
stress management but let's start with
sleep
so how do you start to regulate your
sleep
and how and how is it like sometimes
people i certainly underestimated how
important sleep was
and i did have a period of about three
months where i went to bed and i woke up
at the same time
and i got i think i was eight hours of
sleep
and i felt so much better um but
you know then stress happens and you
can't sleep or
other things happen and your sleep goes
off so how do you suggest
people get their sleep in order and
what's the optimal length of time
what are tricks you can do well actually
you describe it very well
so having a very regular rhythm
in in your sleep patterns i can
also reflect on what i used to have it
was like
you know i used to work at nights so
it could be like upside down so shift
working is the worst it's the
enemy of sleep it's the enemy of you
know you're basically your own health
and also socials jet lag so i used to
party
quite a bit you know from 20s to 30s
then i quit it uh you know
parting in the weekends you go to bed at
3 4
a.m and then you try to wake up in the
morning monday morning
way too early for for the rhythm so
having a
pretty tight schedule like within an
hour
like sleep time when you go to bed wake
up time
when you get out of bed that is the
number one thing
and also having enough time to actually
sleep so if
let's say if you want to sleep eight
hours
i suggest that you have 10 hours to
spend in the bed
so usually people are not that their
sleep efficiency is not
like 90 or 95 it's more like
maybe 85 80 percent of course could be
even worse if you're like
waking up all the time but you know
having enough time for actually
sleep and even better to be like in a
relaxed state
and then after that comes like light
light management in the morning you want
to have
this uh like wide spectrum blue spectrum
lights
basically sunlight which is every
spectrum but
for example listen here in finland at
these times of the year
the sun lies it's it's pretty scarce it
you know it might be two weeks we don't
see any like uh
it's it's gray all day long and then
it's get even darker
towards like the christmas time
but we can have like artificial lights
you know in the studios
these bright lights actually would work
also in the in the morning
you have these specific lights you can
actually have even light glasses that
you have
specific waylands use them 20 minutes
and you can
reset your circuit and biology and the
clocks
in in the specific parts of the brain
but also in the evening you don't want
to have these kind of
lights in the evening and definitely you
don't want to have a
cell phone here bombing like photo like
photonic bumping on your eyes but you
want to have
more of a natural sunset coloring like
the red spectrum of light dimming the
light
red lights and so on so playing with
these natural elements
just to ask a couple of questions about
that so
uh specifically with the light what time
like what's the time frame there were a
lot of people who asked about time
changes and jet lag
and circadian rhythms so what time is it
that you should be having more this
bright
bluer light and what time do you start
toning things down and using more
red light and the purpose of that is for
circadian rhythm
am i correct yeah that's that's very
easy you can think of this two
two rule which i actually just made up
but
you know two hours first two hours of
the day
you wanna have like really bright like
preferably sunlight but if you don't
have it these kind of like very bright
daylight lamps and the last two hours of
your day
you want to really dim it down or only
like red spectrums and
you can have specific like blue light
blocking glasses which i
don't think i have at the moment here
but that's what i've been using maybe
like seven
years already now i usually put them on
three hours before i go to sleep or the
intended sleeping time
and this actually cuts off the blue
light totally
and what it makes it's uh your body
naturally strong
starts uh secreting melatonin which is
the dark hormone
um and that's not gonna be secreted if
you're like having too much bright light
okay and what what kind of glasses do
you use do you have recommendations for
where to go because i know you can get
the kind that are you know
five dollars off of amazon and then
there are a whole bunch of companies
that say they're the best
what i use is our own made like the
bikers and evening glasses
and those are scientific scientifically
validated and
researched and they also actually work
as like a sunglasses so they have uv a
and b
protection but they protect or cut off
almost 100 percent of the blue light and
eighty percent of the green light which
also might have an effect
i can give you links to this uh yeah
yeah sure
yeah i'll put those i have it here so
this is what i've been using oh yeah
okay
so this actually um i kind of like it i
might use it for the rest of the show
i'm somewhat sensitive to these
super bright lights yeah i used to have
this response and i thought i was just
being neurotic
before all this light and i thought a
lot of my reactions were just
neuroticism
but i used to go into places some of the
major stores like walmart
just destroy me and i'm sure it's the uh
the lighting in there i go in there for
like
15 minutes into target or something and
i'm just
dizzy and my dad's got the same problem
or like headaches with fluorescent
lighting
it's just like some people get that yeah
you're probably belonging to that 25
of the people who have this sensory
processing sensitivity sps
which i definitely have and that's why i
also i'm very sensitive to sound and
like malls
are the worst and hospitals
hospitals i know you go in there and
you're already half dead
and they put you under buzzing
fluorescent lights
oh and feed you sugar it's great i try
on recovering
you know in that yeah try sleeping with
all the sounds
too like beeping beeping fluorescent
lights and sugar
here's a place to get better okay okay
so that covers
oh what what do you think about using
something like white noise or those
covers over your eyes for darkness
love it i use yeah i think i've used
them at least 10 years
you know i have this specific like
evening sleep rituals
i use like white noise or pink noise and
atlantic waves and i do meditation i lie
on a spike mat
you know this gives you some endorphins
and oxytocin
a really nice relaxed state and um
yeah that's that's uh definitely
definitely a good technology
and i when i sleep i have the eye mask
and also
like ear plugs so that i don't hear
anything
so i have a pretty pretty loud voiced
daughter
yeah she's almost five
and you know when she was smaller she
used to even like through these
earplugs i could hear her voice and
i'm kind of more of like uh i'm not the
morning person
and uh my wife is a morning person more
and either or they're kind of in the
middle they're not waking up like six
a.m more like
7 38 and i usually you know sleep until
9 30 even 10. what time do you go to bed
uh usually about at midnight so um okay
yeah so that's that's been kind of my
rhythm for the
for all my life so i have very easy i
can i could very easily stay up
as late as i want you know it's it's no
problem so usually when i was on call in
the hospital
i had no problems like staying up but
i couldn't sleep in in the hospital bed
and you know being bombed with lights
and sounds
and then i you know went home at 9am and
tried to sleep for like five hours and
it was kind of a mess so um but my
rhythm is very
like strict it's it's very natural for
me
in in the summer time it's um i wake up
earlier
because it's um you know so much light
and you don't really need
that much sleep in the summer which is
pretty natural
and when it gets darker you naturally
began like craving more sleep
oh okay i didn't know that is that just
part of our slight hibernation
you know it's uh it's everything is
about cycles
we have these microcycles you know the
circadian
rhythm but also we have this microcycles
which are like
the weekly rhythms but also even longer
cycles
which are like the four stages of the
year
and this affects your microbiota this
affects your
chronobiology your hormones the way
you're supposed to
eat so not like eating the same stuff
all the time so
of course you have illness and you
really have to do it then it's uh it's
it's a
no-brainer you said the word
chronobiology
yeah what is that basically it's it's a
biology
around the clocks that regulate our
different kind of systems in our bodies
for example the melatonin system
cortisol secretion system the hba axis
basically most of the hormones
different kind of things that happen in
the body
like regulation of body temperature
regulation of the
blood pressure pulse rate
uh breath rate and so on okay
interesting um how much of what people
get online
isn't true about biohacking like are
there
technological like products that are
being sold that really just don't work
um do you have examples of that what to
avoid
it's frustrating for people to get
started in something and then have a
whole bunch of things not work after
they spend money and then just give up
on the whole
idea that is true it's there's a lot of
charlatans
a lot of like woo stuff
i don't know the exact like percentage
or percentages but i'd say like
maybe even like 75 70 percent this
is not really working and different kind
of like indiegogo game
campaigns for a product that's been like
super advertised
like this this is the life changer this
is the only thing you need
so you really need to be skeptical
actually i don't want to go to sleep
[Laughter]
i want to be a bummer with light but you
know every
like these gadgets and devices that have
like these
ultimate health claims that this is the
one thing you've been like
missing and this will totally fix all of
your problems you have to be really
careful
except for the carnivore yeah i'm just
kidding kind of
take this blue pill this will yeah yeah
yeah
everything true okay okay um what is
that
blue speaking of blue pills what's that
blue thing that i see
people eating in the biohacking
community that turns their tongue blue
yeah that's probably the metal in blue
yeah what is that
i haven't tried that it's it's uh
nowhere to be found in finland
uh it's supposed to be kind of like a
nootropic
giving some energy i haven't really
looked into the science behind that than
the
what's actually behind the bio chemical
pathways and so on
because it's it hasn't been available to
me so
yeah fair okay for no no tropics are
there
or supplements let's let's go to the
supplement route before we finally get
to stress
um are there supplements you suggest
like top three supplements you suggest
everyone take
tricky question uh because everybody is
different
but um taking um
or thinking about worldwide i would say
even like
uh epidemic like
deficiencies in certain nutrients
like vitamin d you know you have been
hearing about vitamin d
you know here and there but that's the
number one because it's such a opponent
regulator of at least 2 000 genes
it's it's putting on like genes on that
actually are helping your system that
are healing
and also like shutting off genes that
might cause disease
so that that would be definitely number
one thing
uh in terms of just micronutrients i
would really
pay attention to iodine because
that's also an epidemic of absence
in many people and especially for women
it would be iron
that's also one of the most common
deficiencies so a lot of people
have have especially women have problems
with the
iron deficiency and they might not even
know it but it might feel like that you
have like a kind of like breaks on
and you don't know what what to do but
you know simple measurements like
uh measuring a 13 usually gives a lot of
um sense to that actually i'm gonna put
this back because my eyes feel better
you can count how many times i switch
this on and off
i i have about 12 pairs of those
i think they're from raw optics in my um
yeah raw objects it's a nice brand yeah
um okay for vitamin d so i know a lot of
people with autoimmune disorders
specifically have low levels of vitamin
d or chronic health problems and that
was one of the
deficiencies i had that didn't actually
write itself
all the way um on the carnivore diet i
had zinc that was really low that fixed
itself
my b vitamins all fixed themselves but
vitamin d i just
couldn't get up and i went to i was
lucky enough to go to like the bahamas
in the wintertime
and it didn't budge i tried i was taking
oral supplements and what i ended up
doing
just for anyone interested is doing the
vitamin d really high dose injections
and i did two of those and my levels
came back up
um which was interesting that's the most
effective way you know
besides uh getting enough sun but uh
many many people are not used to having
like the sunlight
i myself i must i call myself a sun
opportunist because every time there is
sun i'm there because
yeah it is so healing it's not just the
vitamin d
it's all the spectrum of different kind
of radiation
of course the poison is in the dose but
if you get some sunlight every day
that is really gonna you're gonna feel
the effects
and of course that is also based on your
skin type
uh one of the best ways to elevate the
vitamin d levels
it's it's hard for well people i mean
where you are certainly i spent part of
the winter
uh like six or seven weeks in russia in
january
last year oh it was absolutely brutal i
was
like i felt ill the the jet lag and then
being bombarded with
no sun there wasn't even it was just
cloudy and gray for like
seven hours a day it was yeah it was it
was rough
pretty depressing it also affects your
state of mood
and definitely your hormones so you kind
of want to go into like the siberian uh
these
bears to hibernation for four months and
then you know wake up
when the spring comes yeah i felt that
you can also hack this with different
kind of light technologies
so what i i really like to use is the
far infrared sauna so that gives one
spectrum of
what actually you would get from the
sunlight i actually use it like every
morning and evening as part of my
rituals or routines
rather and it feels damn good and uh
that's far infrared light or spectrum
uh you cannot see it but it's a you know
infrared spectrum and also you have
these
near infrared panels which emit
either like visible red light and also
this near infrared light
and uh we have kind of quite a bit of
these um
devices here i have them at home so
especially in the winter time i
you know basically take five to ten
minutes in my face and if i have
if i really want to absorb the light i
usually
like shoot it on my torso
and that's that's really powerful and
it's been researched quite a bit
it's called the mechanism is called
photobiomodulation
it's basically affecting the
mitochondria mitochondria on the cells
the cytochrome c
oxidase which means that you produce
more energy so it's
actually you can download energy
from these light devices to your system
how do you feel about low-level light
therapy low-level light laser therapy
that's basically what i i've been
describing here
it is um it has different names
might be this llt low level laser
therapy
or low level lead therapy
but as i said the photo by modulation is
the
biochemical mechanism behind that and
it's absolutely wonderful
[Music]
there's the finnish guy who is almost a
graduate from the denzel medical school
in helsinki but he has been gathering
this um
data collection of publications of photo
by modulation i think there are now like
5
000 papers wow so
wow okay i'll i'll find that and link
that below too yeah i can
email these things to you yes yes please
um okay that's interesting my mom bought
this
like okay when was it it was probably
15 years ago got this low level light
laser
panel and it was ridiculously expensive
and she was like this is gonna heal
everything
and we thought because she was very into
like
trying so many new things we were like
that is absolutely
insane because it was so long ago um
and then slowly and then also i tried it
on my joints for arthritis and i
it i was so sick that i had hadn't
helped
um but then when i cleaned up my diet
and actually started healing
it i could feel a reduction in
inflammation when i used it
it just hadn't helped when i was like
half dead
but um first fix your diet fix your gut
then comes yeah and then do the other
fancy stuff
okay let's move to stress
so sometimes you're in a situation um so
i've been in a situation for the last
couple of years where i've had a
close family member like on the verge of
death and so
and there are lots of people who are
either dealing with health problems or
in a stressful situation that they can't
get out of so what are some kind of
things you can do
to mitigate the negative effects of
chronic stress on the brain
quite a bit of things so um i'm quite
aware of your
like situation so uh that's uh
quite a story uh yeah i have to say uh
you know these medications and how they
they can actually ruin your life
yeah yeah so uh but you you're very
resilient
uh that's uh really admirable and
uh i'm very stubborn that is also
building
building the character but also making
your
body even stronger so um
we shouldn't avoid stress but of course
in this this kind of
magnitude of chronic stress it is
detrimental because you go
way into the distress that it is really
hard to climb back from there
so uh you can think the stress as this
kind of like a gauss curve so you have
too little stress here
like hypo stress then you have good
stress here
huge stress it usually goes around here
then you have the hyper stress
and when you go over that you have the
distress which is usually
leading to burnout if it's taking too
long
but different kind of elements it's
again we have to
begin from the sleep so uh
nothing is gonna work if you're not
getting enough sleep
and i would say if especially the deep
sleep part
is highly critical because yeah okay so
just to get into that i use this aura
ring
i got an aura ring last year when i was
yet boom
we're in the club nerd club i like the
nerd club
uh anyway i got this aura ring last year
when i was having trouble sleeping like
i
i've always overslept but i just
couldn't sleep from stress and i got
this aura ring and it just
i like destroyed my life because i was
like oh
this explains it so now even if i have a
good
nine hours my deep sleep is at like four
percent
and i can't move it my ram it's all
rem sleep so
i i feel feel for you and uh this is
very common problem
um that is why i actually wrote this
massive
article on how to optimize your deep
sleep it's about 40 pages
uh 200 references i
first wrote it for ben greenfield's site
so you can find it from there and
i the the story behind this is that i
sent him my aura data so uh
i get now anything between
two hours to three hours and 20 minutes
of deep sleep wow
so it definitely hasn't been like this
all the time so i've been using the
o-ring
for over three years and the starting
point
was about 50 to 55 minutes of deep sleep
and it spins like slowly but steadily
like kind of climbing up a lot of things
there are so many things that you can
actually do so um
the things we discussed in the beginning
of the show definitely the most
important
but you can uh hack you can biohack
your body to get more deep sleep and
this is also very
um crucial for stress management and
that then the number one thing if you go
into supplement side
is getting enough magnesium yeah
and not just like any form of magnesium
but i like the magnesium tolerate
magnesium glycinate because it has these
amino acids that are actually
calming inhibitory and they calm your
nervous system they increase the gaba
production
but people usually take okay i take this
one capsule it's it's like
90 milligrams 100 milligrams that
doesn't do
beep so um you need 10 milligrams
per kilogram of body weight
so for example i weigh 95 kilos i take
a thousand milligrams of magnesium every
night
wow okay i might think even more
if i'm doing a lot of exercise and
sports and if there's a lot of chronic
stress and this has been the most
traumatic
effect and i i've been like trying a few
nights when i don't take at all
and it drops and then comes back again
so magnesium glycinate magnesium torade
uh even magnesium malate are but
if you're not remembering these tricky
names
just get enough magnesium for your own
system
and the more ill you are the more
chronically stressed
you are the more you need magnesium
okay um how do you feel about magnesium
l three and eight
uh that is uh particularly good for the
brain
so we know that it is very good in
crossing the blood-brain barrier
and so if you want to really have the
cognitive effects
then that specific form is is the best
one
okay but for sleep you still think the
magnesium glycinate is probably better
than the magnesium
l three and eight it doesn't cross over
you can use both
um glycinate in the sense that glycine
is a calming and inhibiting
inhibitor inhibiting neurotransmitter
by itself but it also boosts the gaba
production
um so besides taking the magnesium i
also take glycine
the amino acid like separates it to get
it even more
so anything between like six to even 10
grams of glycerin
before bedtime it it's it's a game
changer
and also the taurine amino acid uh
you know separately like two three
cramps before bedtime and taurean is
super interesting
in the sense that it's uh it has a very
high antioxidant property but also
very high properties in in boosting the
gaba production
but it's also like productive for the
testicles in men and
for the heart it increases blood flow
uh to the heart and to your overall
system
it's a very very interesting like
substance
interesting okay that's that's cool um
i've
and if people test their magnesium and
their magnesium tests
normal is this still something that
could be beneficial
yes so um i always ask
what does it mean to have normal
and how the magnesium levels are
measured
if it's only like serum magnesium it's
it doesn't tell it's it's uh like one
percent information
because you want to know what's inside
the cells yeah okay
so at least you want to know like the
whole blood level of magnesium
then you can actually say what is the
long-term
amount of magnesium you have and how
much you actually need
so i measured this and even with this
kind of uh
high sounding dose my magnesium still
isn't actually even in the optimal
it could be like now i haven't measured
that in in the year but
uh the recommendations for magnesium
uh that like the rda it's very low
okay okay and some of these tests i know
if you go to a regular doctor at least
in canada you get
up you don't get very much information
from these kind of blood tests but if
you go to a naturopath you can get
intracellular levels and they look at
what's in the cell and those give you a
lot of information
functional medicine doctors for sure
yeah yeah those are impossible to find
in canada they're all
like when i was about five years ago
when i was first
like getting into this um i
tried to find a doctor who knew anything
about nutrition
or even knew what a food sensitivity was
and i found like two of them there there
must be more now that is
that it's later but they were all
completely booked up so i know in canada
it's it's tricky to find somebody maybe
california is better
sounds pretty like similar to finland
i remember when i began doing the
functional medicine practices and
treating people holistically back in
2012 and 13 and suddenly
something happened uh my like doctor's
appointment were booked
like six months ahead uh
of course that was a stressor for me so
because i i i couldn't
you know i couldn't say i know today i'm
not coming so
i had to do it and eventually it led to
me
like downsize my the size and the amount
of
patience i take in you know in practice
to eventually create this book
yeah this one
that guy yeah this is uh oh my phone's
here this is a good one this is
completely full you talk about like you
go into detail enough that
you talk about the optimal office setup
yeah which is something i have to look
at again um what kind of chairs to use
like there's a ridiculous amount of
information in there
indeed and that's uh that's why we call
it the missing manual of the human body
so
we kind of jumped into this topic but
let's um
let's reflect this for a while so uh if
you have a kind of
any like machine car or anything you
have this manual
how to use it how to take care of it but
when you're born
uh of course we have like basic like
school books but
it doesn't really tell you how to take
care of yourself
and that that is the reason we we have
been writing this book
yeah um okay so we covered a lot of what
i wanted to cover
my my uh deep sleep's at 15 minutes like
between 15 and 30
and even if i feel like i had a good
night i just dream it seems
there are so many things that you can do
the red light therapy
actually there are two studies on it
the effects increase the sleep quality
uh one of one was with the chinese
basketball players and the other one i
can't recall but the
these like they probably test everything
on chinese basketball
yeah like the most optimal everything
oh no you can't say that in north
america
okay okay okay um do i have other things
what do you think about the things like
high-dose vitamins like vitamin c
therapy or vitamin drips
yeah in specific situations for sure
vitamin c is pretty interesting because
it's so
diverse the effects especially during
these times of pandemic
it is could be a lifesaver for many
and if your chronicle is stressed what i
did with patients
who uber stressed out they took three to
five times
uh one gram of vitamin c per day
and what it does it kind of down
regulates the overstimulated hp axis
the adrenals actually is the most
important storage for vitamin c in the
body
and also what i've seen that is up
regulates the hrv which is the heart
rate variability which is related to
you know better control of your
autonomic nervous system and balance off
the sympathetic and and the
parasympathetic nodes
so the higher the hrv is usually the
better
the control of your autonomic nervous
system is
so vitamin c is very versatile also
preventing infections especially if you
are an athlete or your chronically
stressed vitamin d
c has been shown to actually prevent
from getting getting like basic flows or
like this or rhinoviruses and so on
and if you're sick it could actually cut
half
of the time that you're spent being sick
so
one of the most important vitamins for
sure and also for stress management
okay um where does where does exercise
fit into this whole biohacking thing is
there an optimal
level optimal type minimal exercise you
need in order to function properly
depends on your goals
everybody needs to move and we are
designed to be
like moving so i've been actually
sitting in this saddle chair but
what i usually do at the office i have
microphones
marker brakes we have like uh pull up
bars we have vibration plates here
i do push-ups kettlebell swings and so
on
and how i think about exercise
movement nowadays is more of like
incorporating this um
micro movements or even like microbore
crop workouts throughout the day
not necessarily destroying myself like
one
one half an hour per day but rather
keeping the constant moving and that's
been shown to be
even more beneficial than having like
let's say like one hour crossfit workout
but if you do these
micro workouts or micro movements
throughout the day
that is uh health wise even better
so um i love the exercise chapter in the
book
that is uh like solely written by me
because i'm i'm exercise enthusiast
so i've been also because of exercising
too much
um being like in the words of burnout so
besides not sleeping enough i used to do
crossfit
six seven times per a week
like in 2009 10 11
12. so i know what's what's
what it's like to be overtrained also
nowadays it's it's more like
what gives you the best bang for the
buck and uh
what is the minimum effective dose
for let's say each day
uh i don't necessarily use any like
specific programs
but it's more like uh in the states it's
more intuitive training
but enough to have like stimuli for
let's say a muscle growth
strength growth developing or vo2 max
and so on so for example what i did
yesterday with my daughter
outside in the dark i did this eight
minute
high intensive repetitive training so
that basically it's
it's not high intensive interval
training when you destroy your entry
reserves but it's more like
the work you do it's about 10 to 12
seconds and then you rest
the rest of the minute and you repeat it
again about eight
eight to ten times and what i did was uh
get a ball swings with a resistance band
to create this really
explosive movement but after the workout
it's like very
fast but you don't feel drained at all
so you can train very um
you can use how would i put it
you don't have to destroy yourself every
time you train let's put it that way
how do you know when you're over
training
uh by feeling uh usually my mood goes
low
and there's actually a questioner called
poms
profile of mood state questioner for
athletes but it could be used for
anybody and usually if you're over
trained your
neurotransmitters go also go pretty low
so the dopamine
goes low serotonin goes low gaba goes
low
and the resource is for for for this is
it's not
in the in the nervous system it's it's
more like
in the recovery state uh
from there on of course measuring the
hrv with the ordering
uh the resting heart rate how fast your
resting heart rate goes
down or if it goes down at all
and these these kind of things but um
the more you get
in tune with your own system and your
body
you don't really need any any
measurements of course they're usable
but um
you kind of get the feeling yeah yeah
and for anybody who doesn't know we've
mentioned the aura ring a number of
times it's just a device that
tracks a number of things that you just
just stick on your fingers it's just
like
super easy super easy yeah and it
connects to your phone it's
finished technology and in the ways oh
really yeah it's it's originated from
here
2015 and 16. but
uh yeah i reached out to them and was
like i want to become an affiliate and
they were like we don't do that
yeah fine we're still buying your ring
but fine
we used to be there like the highest
reseller for
for the orderings until last september
but there you know their policy now it's
a u.s driven and
u.s led company so it's kind of has
changed
yeah um what other you said you had this
what spikey mat which i want i know it's
not called a spiky mat
but swedish spike man swedish yoga mat
with this like
this big spot involved in your yoga mat
um what what kind of like things
that can give people more information or
can help them what kind of things do you
recommend
other than this like i guess the aura
ring the swedish
spike mat red glasses red light clouds
you know
i want to point out about something
about the finnish wild nature so
um do you see this oh
this one over there yeah that's a huge
chaga
let's use chaga mushroom and wow
yeah that's huge yeah you don't you
don't eat it
here's a bit smaller piece of chaga
but how i use it is in a form of
tincture
and this is wild finnish chocolate
tincture
this is an aragenic herb and it's
specially good for your immune system
but it also has
some some like stress system balancing
functions another really good one is
this you have any guests
where am i we used to collect those in
northern saskatchewan growing off of
trees
yeah looks just like it what is that
rishi
oh yeah
and it's uh you know it's actual this is
actual racism this is uh
they're very hard and uh you can use
that as
like a water extract or
what i like better is this alcohol
extract
so rishi is definitely one of my
favorites for
especially for the stress management and
it's also uh really
um how would i put it like quote open
ups the heart
so it's really like warming and uh
almost like uh
opens up more of this intuitive side of
yourself
and it also helps with sleep issues um
for me this basically what it does is uh
i
see a lot more dreams so uh
cool i don't need that really
yeah it looks like it looks like this
and
ah there you have it how does it taste
well interesting interesting
quite bitter but you know i i'm used to
this
and we are quite used to this yeah
another arapgenic herb is rhodiola this
is also the tincture
i don't have the rhodiola the root or
it's it's uh or rhodiola rosea it's it's
the root it grows wild in finland also
in siberia
uh north america also a rodeo is pretty
interesting and there's um
some studies about it and its effect
on or quite diverse effect on different
neurotransmitters
so it's really operating or upregulating
dopamine synthesis
also um has a little calling in a bit
it's kind of like a nootropic as well
and
uh also the gaba system but what i've
used the rodeo life if that if you feel
that your energy is low
or if you're kind of like uh kind of
like sluggish because of too much stress
in that sense rodeo lies it's the
perfect
so i used it seasonally especially
during this dark dark nights
of dark dark season
so um rhodiola one of my favorites
cool rhodiola okay i get i i feel like
when i get hyper stressed i get wired
like i don't i just don't sleep and i'm
completely full of
it's i don't know cortisone adrenaline
definitely
then for you the ashwagandha
well ashwagandha okay if you've heard of
ghana that that would be the best one
that that's been really
shown to decrease the cortisol levels
down regulate the hpa axis
also increase gaba increase more of the
anabolic
hormones and like down regulate the
cortisol production which i
i think i said already but yeah marshall
ghana definitely my favorite for
like for your type yeah okay and
okay these um these supplements like the
ashwagandha and things
are they they're extracts in alcohol
right
um i'm just wondering how much actual
mushroom is there because i
like i said i'm on this diet so i'm
careful
you have to search for certain like um
this is really like
looks super tasty
uh yeah how do you know when you're
buying like how do you know if you're
buying something that's worth buying
yeah good good good stuff there if it
has this
um let's say from ashwagandha you want
to search for
let's say central ashwagandha
or even better would be which is pretty
new
form of that is microcapsulated shodan
ashwagandha you want to go and search
for the
like research on that so what i use i
use
examine.com examine.com
uh just to check out different kind of
uh herbs
and and the state of their research you
want to use them from brands that are
trusted
and also that have laboratory testing
and they have this
like certifications these finnish
companies for example this
these are all from food in they are like
super reliable and absolutely the best
sources from the wild finnish nature
another one i really like another
finnish brand is called
gap health gap health so they have
really high quality uh
medicinal mushrooms but in terms in
general
and like um it's kind of like wild west
you might
not want to go with these chinese
brands unless they are like like
super high quality dragon herbs is is
the one i trust from from the like
chinese manufacturers
okay um and do you look at things like
third-party testing like what are things
on
these websites that you could look for
to clair like to make sure they're
getting something that's high quality
yeah i think there are independent uh
third-party testing
uh annually i don't recall that
the name of of this site but there is
this one side that does
this you know they take a lot of
products
and then they test them for example
let's say for
like whey protein how much it actually
has the whey protein or
different amino acids or let's say
products for magnesium how much it
actually has
the product that is claimed to be in the
label
so um i don't recall what what's the
decide i can come up with this this
that's okay for you later but
tons of information here yeah um
what have you ever had a biohacking
experience
or experiment on yourself that's gone
awry
[Music]
uh yeah we have definitely had like two
long
cold exposure and sauna systems
so i definitely love the whole
hot cold or heat cold alteration therapy
and that's that is one of the best
methods also for the train your nervous
system but
um we had this uh around our biker
summit a few weeks back
we had this upgrade off site in an
island and we spent
two and a half hours uh alternating
between the super cold water
and and the sauna
and i was walking barefoot almost the
whole day
and it was like plus i don't know plus
five
decrease and the water was maybe plus
nine
so uh not going like overboard so um
i felt good at the time and but and and
uh but kind of
had a little payback in terms of like
immunity so i
like felt something like in my system
for a while
so you don't want to go overboard with
anything of course you can
search your limits you can like
experiment with like different
doses uh for different kind of
supplements that are
safe these are extremely safe magnesium
is extremely slave
i see in taurine extremely safe
but let's say for um some some of these
new tropics
that really might have detrimental
effects let's say
like uh uber chain a or
yeah alpha gb cbg that actually could
cause you this cholinergic cholinergic
crisis
and maybe supplements that really boost
the serotonin so you don't want to get
the serotonin syndrome which is pretty
horrible
and let's say like too much of 5 htp
yeah i've had that before yeah i've had
a couple times i had that
a number of times when i was taking i
didn't know i was the young taking
antidepressants and 5htp at the same
time
do not do that it's very unpleasant
cough syrup also interacts with all
those things if it has dextromethorphan
so do not do those things it can cause
serious yeah
yeah yeah yeah you gotta be like wise
and
and a bit like not paranoid but careful
you know um
to do your research and the interactions
are for sure for real
and for example for reishi i would
induce that uh
if i had a severe autoimmune like
condition because it actually
could even boost the inflammation
even more that's good to know and raises
it's definitely like an
autoimmune or immune regulator so i it
might
boost it or it might lower it but you
you never know what you're gonna get
so have you had any experiment uh
experience with peptides
using peptides for leg wound healing
i've read about a lot um them but the
the
sad point is that we don't have them in
finland and uh
there's no way to be like get get get
them from here
and i have no idea about the legislation
in here
but i'm like very aware and familiar and
i've been reading about this quite a bit
so uh
in in my um research
uh what i think would be the most safest
and probably
one of the best ones would be the bpc157
you know as a overall uh like a
regenerator
of different kind of tissues so that
seems to be the most
safest one cool okay
a few more questions um just some fun
ones how about what's the so you went
over
biohacking technology i like all this
tech stuff because they need
to measure more of what's going on and
sometimes more information is better
um sometimes if you're very ill it's you
just have to start
in one place and like calm down your
slight say sleep and diet
before you look it in every certain
direction but um
do you have like best bio hacking tech
that's on the more affordable side you'd
recommend people get
yeah well obviously i love the ordering
at one point
i used to have like three different
devices that measured my stress and
sleep so i used to have the bias trap
i'm not having it at the moment and also
the garmin's we will move hr which
measures the
the hrv and and the recovery
throughout the day but if in terms of
like using an actual
tick so definitely these um the red
light
infrared light therapies and the devices
are the ones to go
so the effects are so
immediate and they are very safe when
you use it properly
and also it can be used for many things
um i love these small
spotlights i don't know if you have any
of this here we actually have
one over there but it's it's not on but
it's kind of like
this this size spotlight you have a
switch on and it has
both the red and the infrared spectrum
and you can like use it
anywhere you want oh cool so yeah so
that is something i
i take um with me when when uh when i
travel
when when travel is again allowed when
that happens if that happens um
do you have i i have panels i have one
juve panel and i have a whole bunch of
panels from red light rising
um yeah which i like and i think they
also have one of those smaller
more portable spot lights but what
company are you using for your
panels yeah um i used i
i have had the two for over four years
now it uh kind of uh
broke down i also have the big red light
rising
uh the full stack panel yeah but
nowadays we
actually make the panels ourselves so
okay that's cool yeah and we i i have to
say that
uh when you compare the quality to these
two brands
it is uh right there or even a slightly
better so
um it's not that noisy it's it's a bit
more like
this sounds like a commercial but uh you
know we we make barker's
panels and also these uh spotlights
so this is this is the spotlight yeah
that looks handy for traveling i've
missed my red light
track let's
all right so um
oh wow and do you use that for
um oh yeah it's very bright do you use
that for
like sleep or wound healing
you know if i want energy i might use it
like in the forehead um
what i've seen really actually working
is uh
stimulating your thyroid so just uh
using it here for
five to ten minutes if i have let's say
i have like uh
some soreness in in the elbow like five
minutes there
you know wherever um depends on
what i need or just you know have a
little bit of energy to the face
and you absorb the photons of course you
can use it for your own skin
skin health that's really prominent
effects on the skin health and
a lot of things you can actually do
but or how we use it i use it in the
evenings
as just you know as a light yeah
okay you don't watch it straight you
know it's not
harmful to your eyes of course if you
use it like
many hours like straight and just watch
it but it has actually been shown even
to
kind of like treat these regional
problems in the eye
so you can use for therapy for your eyes
i like that i want one of those portable
portable spotlights that looks
that looks very helpful um okay last
question
how do you know like how how
scientifically how do you measure
the effect of putting a red light on
your forehead
how do we even know that that helps
well you don't you could measure it
with let's say some kind of pet scan
you know when you have when you see the
metabolic effects in the front lobes of
your brain but
who does that like anywhere else than in
hospital
uh in hospital settings of course you
have science and
you have this the view light company
that have these uh
big like things on your head yeah
and also in the internet knows and they
have published really good
research and the papers are really solid
so uh in that sense they are actually
measuring but
quantifying that for yourself it's uh
not really possible at
you know at the moment yeah well i was
super skeptical about
light because the most effective thing
for me has been a
diet by far and then i've i've noticed
uh
sleep for sure that's an obvious one
exercise so i've been super skeptical
about red light
although i know that certain types of
light
really bother me i'm still fairly
skeptical
but i have found that the red light can
be helpful
for um especially when i used to get
these rashes
and i found that the low level laser
therapy really helped um
with rashes and it does give fill me
with a sense of like wonderful calm
so there's there's i like them i bring
them around
as you said there are companies and
there are products
that uh work a little bit better and
then there are products that are
promising too much and and they're not
what they're supposed to be or what
they're saying so
um our motto is kind of uh going in the
middle
like the golden mean or the golden
pathway
not going in too much into extremes in
either side
so we are not like super overly overly
scientific
uh of course the book is but we keep our
minds open
uh when i say uh we i mean
the company and my colleagues in here
and and
uh overall the finnish biohackers and we
combine the technology and the nature
but we don't go crazy
like either way so usually the truth is
being found somewhere
in the middle-ish but of course you want
to be like experimented
and you want to uh try on
different things whether it works for
you so that's that's the only thing that
actually matters
that it works for you but it is uh
more worthwhile trying if there is some
science behind something
but you you know new innovations they
don't necessarily come up with like
ready
science it's usually there's an invasion
and then you do the science and then you
have validation
okay well that was fascinating and i'm
gonna link everything we talked about
below which was a lot um thank you so
much for coming
on i'm very excited about this episode
oh thank you thanks mia it was a
[Music]
pleasure
you